У червні збираємо полуницю.
Висаджуємо її.
Закінчується полуниця — починається «пекінка».
І так само серпень, вересень, жовтень
і цілу зиму продаємо пекінську капусту.
Потім знову починається полуниця.
Такий трудомісткий процес, треба багато людей.
Там сусіди, там діти допомагають.
Майже через хату тим займаються.
Діляться інформацією, ніхто нічого не приховує.
Нема як такої роботи. Зайнялися цим.
Я думаю, що це добре.
Оце ми висаджуємо в поле.
І виростає пекінська капуста з нього.
Оце все — 24 гектари.
Це розсада полуниці.
Тут ще корінь слабкий де-не-де.
Повністю заплете корінь,
тоді вона буде висаджуватися в поле.
От так, ще трошки.
Отакий кущик.
Коли велике сонце, то ми накриваємо сіткою.
Щоб не будувати теплицю, то на землі [садимо].
І воно досить непогано виходить.
Це тара. Отак ми зберігаємо капусту.
Воно ставиться у висоту 6 метрів, ящик на ящик.
Картонний просто не витримає.
Я в Луцьку жив.
Це з нуля починали.
Я приїхав почав хазяйнувати.
У мене один трактор Т-16 був.
Такий, знаєте. Більше нічого не було.
Все будували своїми силами.
Тут в мене...
Як треба люди живуть, зверху там.
Поробив кімнати.
Це коли в нас сезон полуниці.
Тут зберігаю пекінську капусту.
До 100 тон полуниці вдень. Літом село продає.
Не я, а село в цілому.
Вдень, бувало, по три фури
завантажували пекінською капустою.
Луцьк стільки не з'їсть.
Київ, Рівне бере, але більшість
пішла цього року на Білорусію.
А далі куди вона їде, я не знаю.
Як починалось? 10-12  років тому.
Поїхали в Польщу, попрацювали.
Місяці 2-3.
І подумали, що вдома можна посадити
все те, що ми робимо в поляків.
Працювали в хорошого пана.
Розказав як що, дав розсаду.
Приїхали, посадили.
З кожним роком трошки більше і більше.
Возили, возили перший рік на ринок. Продавали.
Торгували по кілограмах.
Потім почали приїжджати машини.
Тільки не один продає,
а все село по пару кілограм скидається.
От їде машина, продає в Київ, продає закордон.
Так воно все і робилось.
І по сьогоднішній день так робиться.
Ця розсада  через 2-3 дні
буде висаджуватись в поле.
На мій погляд досить непогана розсада.
Так що її ми не тільки для себе.
А можна й продати.
А на мій погляд вона ідеальна, Вітя.
Ану підніми, переверни палету.
Подивіться. О, бачите?
Отакої розсади декілька тисяч могли би і продати.
В основному ми садили мармеладу, але зараз
люди хочуть більш таких ексклюзивних...
Ексклюзивної ягоди.
Наступного року, якщо все добре,
вона прийметься в полі.
Якщо гарно її доглянути, наступного року
буде повноцінний урожай.
— Стараюся своїми силами переважно.
— Так, в основному своїми силами.
Допомога одне одному, то трактор, то ще щось.
З людьми дуже важко.
І більшість їде до Польщі.
Показуємо, показуємо, що можна не їхати.
Так наше село можна сказати, що й не їздить.
Ми теж довгий час, попрацювали там.
Побачили, що можна вдома щось вирощувати.
Просто в людини є креативне мислення, розумієте?
Якщо хтось може, то я що гірший чи що?
В селі офіційно живуть 757 людей.
Так більш-менш, або хтось живе, або не живе.
Хтось живе без реєстрації.
Це адміністративне приміщення,
яке було до 2016 року на балансі радгоспу.
Потім в 2016 році його передали на наш баланс.
Отут ми плануємо створити логістичний...
Логістичний центр — це трохи загучно сказано.
Ми створимо тут кабінет
для наших усіх одноосібників.
Буде комп'ютеризований.
І тут оці люди зможуть зібратися,
обговорити свої проблеми.
Є люди, які займаються суто питаннями реалізації, збуту.
Ринки шукають і так далі.
Щось таке подібне вони будуть створювати тут.
Я думаю, до кінця цього року все буде
в цьому приміщенні зроблено вже.
Початкова перша атака зроблена.
Але це трохи пізніше.
Спершу треба дати людям можливість
працювати і заробляти — це в першу чергу.
На тому ми й стоїмо.
У нас люди всі працьовиті,
всі завзяті, як і вся Україна.
Вже все більше і більше підхоплюють.
Сусідні села підхоплюють.
Приїжджають, запитують і щось тоже садять.
Але в основному, то Хорохори садять.
Оце хлопці, які почали відроджувати село.
Були одні пенсіонери, які чекали пенсії,
поки їм поштарка принесе, і то все.
Ото все було, що було.
А сьогодні, Слава Богу,  кожна людина
має можливість заробити якусь копійку.
Хай трошки, але садить, садить.
Вони ще вкладають, оці хлопці,
які перші, вони ще вкладають.
Цьогоріч купили першу машину,
що стелиться. Ні, минулого року.
А цього року хочуть купити ту, що сапає.
На місці стояти — це не є рух вперед.
На цьому не можна зупинятися.